premier match et première défaite pour
plaisir en fédérale 2 ce dimanche 9
septembre les jaune et bleu n'ont pas
réussi à rivaliser avec le marcquois
rugby dans leur stade
le score est sans appel 51 13 quand on
maîtrise aussi peu de chose à un moment
donné la sanction est un peu obligatoire
et ouais notamment les 3 4 premiers
essais comprends c'est que des défauts
de notre parc peu l'adversaire va
utilise à fond voilà donc un problème
c'est logique au total les visiteurs ont
inscrit huit essais dont cinq en
deuxième période
une faillite défensive qui s'explique
principalement par une reprise tardive
des entraînements pour une partie du
groupe
c'est vrai que par rapport à ces grosses
écuries ont certainement des moyens
différents des nôtres et ils ont repris
l'entraînement beaucoup plus tôt que
nous c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
jeu est beaucoup plus vils et de leur
côté quoi on est sûr à un groupe qui
bouge un peu ce talent et les garçons
qui nous ont rejoints les automatismes
sont pas là les repères de chaussures
pas encore là voilà on va travailler
tous ensemble pour essayer d'améliorer
tout ça avec ce résultat plaisir pointe
à la dernière place du championnat de
fédérale 2 pour ne pas se mettre en
difficulté dans la course au maintien
une réaction des plaisirs où est attendu
dès le dimanche 7 septembre face à
gennevillois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]